قد يكون هناك خراب من حولهم ولكن
اتجاههم هو الأمام، نحن مع فرقة
مشاة البحرية الأوكرانية الخامسة والثلاثين
أول مراسلين يصلون إلى
ضواحي أوروجينيا،
ومع ذلك تم الإعلان عن تحرير قرية أخرى
يوم الأربعاء،
وقد تكون الانتصارات صغيرة ولكنها
ثابتة، لذا
هنا
مدينة أخرى  نظرًا لأن
الهجوم المضاد يتقدم للأمام، فقد
رأينا للتو القرية المجاورة قد تم الاستيلاء عليها
الأسبوع الماضي لكنهم استمروا في التحرك بشكل
جيد ولم
يكن هناك الكثير من الدخول، سنخرج من
هنا بأسرع ما يمكن بينما يسيطرون على
الأصل، الروس يبذلون كل ما في
وسعهم ل  جعل وجود الأوكرانيين هناك كابوسًا،
أظهرت لنا الوحدة القتال العنيف الذي
التقطته طائرة بدون طيار،
وهذه دبابتهم تتقدم وهي تسقط
سلسلة من المتفجرات المضادة للألغام خلفها، كما
قالوا، وبمجرد أن انفجرت،
أصدرت الوحدة مقطع فيديو لهم في
البلدة يوم الأربعاء حول كيفية توجيه قوتهم
النارية نحو ما كان في السابق معقلًا روسيًا
قصفهم،
يتذكر قائد السرية عددًا أكبر بكثير من الروس
المختبئين هناك مما كان يتوقع،
مات الكثير منهم، كما يقول خاصة عندما
بدأوا في الفرار وعندما احتفظوا
بالكثير منهم في المنازل  لقوا حتفهم هناك
ولكن تم القبض عليهم أثناء فرارهم من
الدخان المحيط بالروس، والذي من المحتمل أنه صنع بواسطة
الذخائر العنقودية.
وقالت أوكرانيا إنها تستخدم بالفعل
بعض الطلقات التي زودتها بها الولايات المتحدة بشكل مثير للجدل،
ولا يمكننا تأكيد ما إذا كانت تلك التي تم إطلاقها هنا
هي القنابل العنقودية الأمريكية الجديدة
ولكن الخسائر  كانت المعاناة واضحة
ويقولون إن استخدامها أقل
معضلة أخلاقية عندما تكون في هذه
المعركة الوحشية،
لا أفهم ذلك، يقول إن هذا الموقع
يستخدم ما يريدون، شعبنا
يموت من كل هذا ولا بأس
عندما يكون الآخر  أنا لا
أفهم
الأغنية التي
تظهر لقطاتها مدى صغر سن البعض في
الهجوم. ليس لديه وقت
للمحللين الغربيين الذين يقولون إن هذا يجب أن يتحرك
بشكل أسرع.
أود أن أقول إنه يمكنهم دائمًا القدوم إلي
كضيف والقتال معي.  يقول لي إذا كان
شخص ما يعتقد أنه يمكنك التحليق فوق
Minefield على مكنسة كما في هاري
بوتر، فلن يحدث ذلك في قتال حقيقي
إذا كنت لا تفهم أنه يمكنك الجلوس
على كرسيك وتناول الفشار الخاص بك
نعم تشمه  هنا، في
الشهر الأخير من التقدم، أشعر بالفراغ
والمشقة على حد سواء، الآن مع الموتى الروس الذين
لم يتحركوا ربما بقدر ما يشعرون به،
هذه الحقول الزراعية الفارغة
التي مات فيها الكثيرون لأخذ كل
كيلومتر يفكر فيه الروس بشدة هنا
استخدم هذه الآلة لإحداث
الكثير من الضرر، ومن الصعب أن نتخيل
ما هي الخطط التي كانت لدى موسكو هنا على الإطلاق
لو احتفظوا بها نيك بايتون والش سي إن إن
بالقرب من أوكرانيا